>> SHE IS FIERCELY LOYAL.
SHE SAID PERHAPS
PROBLEMATICALLY BEFORE THE
HOUSE COMMITTEE YESTERDAY.
SHE TELLS WHITE LIES ON
BEHALF OF THE PRESIDENT.
SO I ASSUME SHE WILL AT THIS
POINT TO DEFEND HIM AND DO
WHATEVER SHE CAN TO PROTECT
HIM WHEREVER SHE MAY BE.
>> DEFINE WHITE LIE.
DEFINE NON-SUBSTANTIVE LIE.
>> HOPE HICKS HAD A VERY
ELEVATED POSITION WITH TRUMP
AND HER LOILTD TO HIM HELPED
GARNER THAT.
BUT THIS IS NOT A
BATTLE-TESTED PERSON WHO
KNOWS HOW TO WEATHER STORM.
>> THINGS ARE ABOUT TO GET
PRETTY UGLY INSIDE THE WHITE
HOUSE AND THE QUESTION IS
FOR SOMEBODY LIKE HOPE
HICKS, WHY DID YOU STAY THAT
LONG?
SHE HAS GOT TO GET READY FOR
MUELLER.
A TRIAL.
I MEAN, IT'S THINGS COULD
GET UGLY.
>> Sean: JOE HAS LOST HIS
MIND OBVIOUSLY.
THE DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA
HAVING THEIR FIELD DAY
FOLLOWING YESTERDAY'S
ANNOUNCEMENT HOPE HICKS THAT
SHE WAS RESIGNING HER
POSITION AT WHITE HOUSE
COMMUNICATIONS DIRECTOR.
JOINING US NOW WITH
REACTION.
HE WAS THERE HIMSELF.
FORMER WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF
STAFF REINCE PRIEBUS.
FIRST OF ALL, I DEFY ALL OF
THESE PHONY OVERPAID
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS
HYPOCRITE COLLEAGUES THAT
ARE LAZY BEYOND BELIEF.
OKAY, THIS IS A WHITE LIE.
THE PRESIDENT WOULD LOVE TO
BE ON WITH YOU LIBERAL JOE,
BUT, HE IS BUSY THAT DAY.
OKAY?
MEANING THE PRESIDENT HAS NO
INTENTION.
OR REINCE, YOUR TIE LOOKS
ACTUALLY LOOKS GREAT TONIGHT
WHEN I REALLY THINK YOUR TIE
THAT'S A WHITE LIE.
AND THEY HAVE ALL TOLD THEM.
>> I MEAN, LOOK, THIS IS
PART OF WHAT IS DRIVING
MONEY IN THE MEDIA IS IT'S
TRUMP WORLD.
IT'S TRASHING TRUMP.
IT'S ALL PART OF WHAT HAS
BEEN HAPPENING SINCE DAY ONE
WITH THE PRESIDENT.
LOOK, I MEAN, YOU LOOK AT
WHAT IT IS LIKE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE.
YOU ARE WORKING LIKE A DOG.
YOU ARE GETTING DESTROYED IN
THE PRESS.
MANY OF THESE PEOPLE ARE
SPENDING HUNDREDS OF HOW FAR
TO SANDS OF DOLLARS ON
LAWYERS.
AND YOU KNOW, AND YOU LOOK
AT THE RESULTS.
>> Sean: PAY MORE LAWYERS.
>> HAVE TO GO TO HELL AND
BACK IN ORDER TO GET THERE,
SEAN.
>> Sean: THIS IS ANOTHER
THING.
THE MEDIA WILL SAY OKAY,
WELL, DONALD TRUMP IS NEVER
GOING TO BE SOMEBODY HE IS
NOT.
HE IS NOT GOING TO BE THE
PRESIDENT.
THE MAINSTREAM ESTABLISHMENT
PRESIDENT THAT THEY WANTED
ELECTED.
THEY WOULD HAVE HAD THAT
WITH HILLARY.
HE IS HIS OWN MAN.
SO, IF THE PRESIDENT EVENTS
OR TWEETS THAT HE IS ANNOYED
WITH SOMETHING, IS THAT HOW
HE MAKES DECISIONS OR IS IT
PART OF A PROCESS?
>> THAT'S JUST IT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE VOTED FOR A
DISRUPTER.
BUT WHAT I ALWAYS TRY TO
EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE ALL THE
TIME IS THAT THE MEDIA IS
OBSESS YOU HAD WITH THE
DECISION-MAKING PROCESS.
WHO IS IN, WHO IS OUT.
WHO IS UP, WHO IS DOWN.
TWEET OF THE DAY.
>> Sean: PALACE INTRIGUE.
>> THIS IS A PRESIDENT WHO
MAKES DECISIONS.
HE MEASURES THINGS OUT HE
PUTS REALLY SMART PEOPLE
THAT MIGHT NOT AGREE WITH
EACH OTHER IN THE SAME ROOM.
I TELL PEOPLE FOCUS ON THE
RESULTS.
LOOK AT THE RESULTS.
REMEMBER FOUR THINGS.
FEDERAL JUDGES AND GORSUCH.
ISIS, REGULATIONS, TAX CUTS,
THOSE FOUR THINGS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE RESULT US
OF BLOO THIS PRESIDENT HAS
ACCOMPLISHED AND YOU ITS NOR
THE PALACE INTRIGUE.
IGNORE WHAT THE MEDIA WANTS
TO TALK ABOUTER DAY THAT
DOESN'T METER.
>> IN ENERGY INDEPENDENCE.
>> CAN'T FIND A WHOLE LOT
THAT HASN'T BEEN
ACCOMPLISHED.
>> Sean: LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS TODAY
STATISTICS 4ODAY
STATISTICS 49DAY
STATISTICS 49 YY
STATISTICS 49 YEAR LOW OF
UNEMPLOYMENT ISSUES.
>> HERITAGE FOUNDATION.
LOOK AT THE HERITAGE
FOUNDATION.
THEY SAID SATURDAY 64%.
>> Sean: OF HIS AGENDA.
>> AND I WOULD TELL YOU THAT
THE HERITAGE FOUNDATION
WAS -- THEY WERE NO BIG
PRO-TRUMP ORGANIZATION WHEN
DONALD TRUMP WENT DOWN THAT
ESCALATOR.
SO IT'S NOT LIKE OUR TRUMP
CHEERLEADERS OUT THERE
MAKING THESE NUMBERS UP.
IT'S ACTUALLY TRUE.
ADAM SCHAAF ADMISSION.
I THOUGHT THEY DESTROYED HIM
ON THE VIEW.
>> SHE DID.
>> I GIVE HER ALL THE CREDIT
NUT WORLD.
SHE DID A AGAIN NOMINAL JOB.
ADAM SCHIFF, OH, IT'S ALL IN
THE PUBLIC ARENA ENOUGH TO
ABOUT TRUMP-RUSSIA
COLLUSION.
I'M LIKE IS THERE ANY
EVIDENCE?
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN ANYTHING?
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T.
>> I HAVE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING.
I HAVE BEEN TOLD BY HIGH
RANKING MEMBERS OF THE FBI
AS I MENTIONED BEFORE.
I WON'T GET INTO IT AGAIN.
THEY FLAT OUT TOLD ME ONE OF
THE ARTICLES, THE ORIGINAL
"NEW YORK TIMES" ARTICLE
THAT APPARENTLY WON AN AWARD
THE OTHER DAY FOR JOURNALISM
WAS OVERSAFETY YOU HAD,
UNTRUE, AND MANY OTHER
THINGS ABOUT IT.
THESE WERE PEOPLE FROM THE
FBI IS THAT TOLD ME THIS.
LOOK, I HAVE NEVER SEEN IT I
KNOW THE PRESIDENT HATES IT.
AND HE HATES WATCHING IT.
BUT I WOULD JUST SUGGEST TO
AS ALWAYS MOVE FORWARD.
>> Sean: ALSO A QUESTION
JUST BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT
VETS AT A MEETING I WANT TO
FIRE THAT ERROR DOES HE MEAN
IT WHEN HE SAYS IT OR IS IT
PART OF A PROCESS.
>> NO, LISTEN.
THERE IS A PROCESS.
THERE WAS A PROCESS WHEN I
WAS THERE.
SAME PROCESS THAT WAS
FOLLOWED BY RONALD REAGAN
AND BUSH 43.
THERE IS A PRINCIPLES
COMMITTEE WHERE MAJOR
DECISIONS ARE BROUGHT
THROUGH WITH ALL THE
PRINCIPLES OF THE WHITE
HOUSE.
MAJOR DEPARTMENTS.
GENERAL COUNSELS.
THEY ALL COME UP TO THE
PRESIDENT WITH A DECISION
MEMO IN HAND PRESENTED TO
THE PRESIDENT FOR A
DECISION.
NOW, THERE ARE SOME THINGS
THOUGH THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE UNDERSTAND THAT THE
PRESIDENT AT TIMES GETS
TIRED OF WAITING ON.
IF HE KNOWS WHAT HE IS GOING
TO DO.
>> Sean: RIGHT.
>> ABOUT THE ISSUE IN
REGARDS TO SAY TRANSGENDER
IN THE MILITARY.
IS HE GOING TO MAKE A
DECISION.
HE HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT
STEEL TARIFFS SIPS THE
1980S.
I MAY NOT BE A BIG FAN OF
STEEL TARIFFS BUT THIS IS
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
AGENDA IS ALL ABOUT.
THE STAFF IS CHARGED WITH
EXECUTING THE AGENDA OF THE
PRESIDENT.
AND THE AGENDA OF THE
PRESIDENT IS GETTING DONE
AND IT'S WORKINGS FOR THE
AMERICAN ECONOMY.